I need this Ovalle right now I'm so
happy oh my god I love you
hello I'm Bryce Anders this is how sighs
happy hour and bethany frankel is here
and I'm excited thank you for having um
cheers to you you have not been a good
friend to me really are you kidding me
Bethany are you kidding me
we're back in the bezerk shirts we're
back in the berserk shears and that
place and I do not get along the minute
I get there my head spins around like
The Exorcist so everybody has teased me
this big blowout coming between you and
Ramona a friendship ending blowout yes
you keep thinking that it's going to
just calm down at some point and it
doesn't in fact it just goes off the
rails
it gets really intense and I just think
that I'm so mesmerizing stunned that I
just don't really even know what to do
with that friendship anymore I would
just stick her in a box I would and I
may but I haven't yet so while she's not
stuck in a box I have to deal with her
right what do you stand today
Ramona's texted me about her daughter
getting a job in business and I said
wonderful congratulation I want the best
for her completely but I don't have to
want to be her good friend right and
that's kind of a little liberating
cheers - thank you we got a drink these
whole cocktail a 10 minutes
except your daughter babe and sway oh
god no my door would never act like that
it's not gonna be all drama we see you
get naked kissing Sonia how do we get to
that point we get to that point okay we
get at that point you know quiz you we
go on a trip that I am hosting which
means that the alcohol is flowing this
is a Mexico trip that could it did and
would and and and you know Mexico and me
and my margaritas and this is the end of
the season so we all are like pressure
cookers ready to blow and it does and
it's pure comedy it's drama and
craziness but it's so funny people don't
know where their pants are people are
slipping by the people's beds not one
dinner had every cast made that it was
never a full group of housewife somebody
fell somebody passed out somebody's in
the pool somebody's naked there was just
no way to get a group together for
dinner okay I get out of the pool naked
and look over and Sonja's wearing my
bathing suit which I'm Anna where the
hell is her thing been yeah I don't know
now it's like is that my bathing suit
still or do I have to give that to you
yeah Wow do I love that I jumped in a
pool naked maybe not but I did I liked
when my boobs looked someone else was
talking about they're moving like look
at my boobs pulled it off had was fueled
on booze and just ran in the pool and
had a very long conversation much longer
because I forgot that I was naked I was
doing like a TED talk I was just like
doing it you know I was doing a seminar
and forgot that I was naked I love it
here's to you thank you for stopping by
for health place happy hour I like this
yeah thanks fun right a dreary fine